welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus Docker and I'm
here with Samuel Hammond who is a senior
Economist at the foundation for American
innovation Samuel welcome to the podcast
hi guys thanks for having me fantastic
all right I have so much I want to talk
to you about but I think a natural place
to start here would be with your
timelines to AI why is it that that you
expect AGI to get here before most
people well I don't really know what
most people think I think there's the
world divides into people who are paying
attention and people who are you know
basically normies and in my day job I
work on Capitol Hill and in Washington
DC talking to folks about Ai and if you
think about sort of what people's
implicit timelines are right you can
sort of read out people's implicit
timelines by their behavior right you
know I I know Paul Cristiano has near
short timelines because he puts he's
doubled up into the stock market right
he's sort of practicing uh what he
preaches but then when you have you know
Sam Altman testifying toward to Congress
I like to say people are taking him
seriously but not literally right he's
saying we're going to develop something
like AGI potentially this decade and
super intelligence thereafter and then
you know you have folks like Senator
Marsha Blackburn being like what would
this mean for music
royalties and um you know when when the
focus of policy makers is things like
music royalties or um you know the
impact on copyright it's not that those
are invalid issues it's that they Bell
relatively longer timelines and then we
also have this definitional confusion
where folks like y Lon would say AGI is
probably decades away because he is
using AGI to mean something that learns
like a human learns in the sense that
it's born as a relative blank slate and
sort of can acquire language with with
you know very few examples so people
have these moving gold posts of what
they mean for me you know I I think we
can sort of avoid Avid those
definitional conflicts if we just talk
about you know human level intelligence
and and you know human humans are quite
General we're generally intelligent
that's what separates us from animals um
in a lot of respects and when you look
at how machine learning models are being
trained today like large language models
and now multimodo models they're being
trained on human data and they're being
trained to reproduce the kinds of
behaviors and tasks and outputs that
humans output and so they're kind of
like an indirect way of emulating human
intelligence and and so and so if you if
you Benchmark AI progress to that then
you can sort of put information
theoretic bounds on you know what what
what's the likely timeline to basically
an ideal human emulator something that
can extract the sort of Base
representations the internal
representations of our brain through you
know the indirect path of the data that
our brain generates yeah you have an
interest in sentence where you write
that AI can advance by emulating the
generator of human generated data which
is simply the brain do you think this
Paradigm holds all the way to AGI I
think it holds this decade to systems
that in principle can in context learn
anything humans do again this is a
semantic question do you want to call
that AGI or not I think there are still
outstanding issues around you know the
limits of other aggressive models for
autonomy and you know the question of of
sort of real- time learning the way we
train these models we sort of are
freezing a crystal in place and and
humans are continuously learning so
there still are genuine you know
potential architectural gaps but you
know from the Practical point of view
from the economic point of view we don't
need to debate whether something is
conscious or whether something learns
strictly the way humans learn if if it
demonstrably can do the things humans do
right and that and that goes to the
original Insight of the Turing test
right you know it's sometimes presented
as a thought experiment but what Allen
Turing was getting at was if you can't
distinguish between the human and a
computer in some ways
indistinguishability implies competence
right and we can broaden that from just
language because arguably we've we've
surpassed the Turning test at least a
weaker version of it uh to think to
human performance on tasks in general
right if we have a A system that can
output a scientific manuscript that
experts in the field can't distinguish
from a human then debating whether the
whether this is real AGI or not is I
feel academic it is surprising in a
sense that that when you interact with
gp4 for example and it it can do all
kinds of amazing things and organize
information present information to you
but then it can't or at least at some
point it couldn't answer questions about
the world after September 2021 or a date
like that that would be surprising if
you if you presented that fact to to an
AI scientist 20 years ago for how long
do you think we'll remain in this
Paradigm of training a foundational
model and then deploying that model um I
mean it's worse than that I think was
surprised people five years ago progress
has started moving along two tracks
there's the industry track and the pure
research academic track and um and
they're obviously having feedback with
one another the pure industry track is
just looking to create tools that are
you know have practical value and can
improve products and so forth and so you
know meta has their own GPU cluster and
their training models so they they they
can have fun chat bots in their in their
messenger and so you know those kinds of
things are going to progress I think
well within current the current Paradigm
because we know the Paradigm works you
know basically deep learning and
Transformers um and you know there's
lots of merchin Alia on the side but
that basic framework seems to to be
quite effective and just scaling that up
because we haven't sort of Hit the range
of irreducible loss and what and what
Transformers can do meanwhile there's
also this parallel pure research track
where people on seemingly a weekly basis
are finding you know better ways of
specifying the loss function uh ways of
of improving upon power loss scaling and
all these all these different uh
sometimes they're new architectures but
often they're just like bags of tricks
and um and those bags of Tricks then you
know to the extent that they they
comport with the the Paradigm Industries
uh running with they can be re
reintegrated and and end up accelerating
progress in Industry as well so do you
think scale of compute is the main
barrier to getting to to human level
AI yes right I mean it's not all we need
but it's it's the main unlock right to
what extent can can more Compu compute
be used to to trade off for lower
quality data or for lower quality
algorithms can you just throw more Compu
and and solve the other the other
factors in that equation it depends on
on the thing you're trying to solve for
in principle if if we're talking about
you know mapping inputs to outputs then
you know Transformers are known to be
Universal function approximators and and
so and so the answer is yes you know
that doesn't mean that they're
necessarily efficient at approximated
everything we want them to approximate
and and sometimes Universal function you
know approximation theorems can be kind
of trivial because they'll be like okay
if your neural network has infinite
width then yes we can approximate
everything the the key fact is both that
they're Universal approximators and and
also that they're relatively sample
efficient at least relative to things we
found in the past and so that to me
suggests that yes they can compensate
for things that they're bad at um on the
other hand the way research is trending
is towards these mixed models
um ensembles of different kinds of
architectures things like the the recent
Q Transformer that's from Deep Mind
which is uses a combination of
Transformers and Q learning to have sort
of the associational memory and and um
and Sample efficiency of Transformers
with the ability to assign policies to
do tasks that you get from reinforcement
learning so I imagine that there's going
to be all kinds of mixing and matching
the key the key point is
that in that space of architecture It's
relatively sort of finite search space
right and as an economist you know
economists believe that Supply is long
run elastic right and so you know
there's this famous bet from uh between
Paul erck and Julian Simon Visa the
population bomb and whether population
growth would lead to sort of a
malthusian purge and Julian Julian
Julian Simon being the economists
recognize that you know if prices rise
for these core Commodities then that
will spur research and and development
into extracting new res new resources
right so he didn't he didn't have to
know that fracking would be a technology
he he understood that if oil prices went
too high people would find new oil
reserves and I think there's I have an
analogous instinct when it comes to
progress in deep learning it meaning you
can become too anchored to sort of the
current state of literature but over a
10-year Horizon you can say well there
there's a huge search on a huge goal
rush to find the right way of of
blending these architectures and I don't
need to know in advance which is the
right way to do that to have high
confidence that someone will find it
yeah we can sometimes if we're too deep
in the in the literature we might lose
the focus on on on the forest for for
the trees in a sense and and if we zoom
out we can just see that there's more
investment there's more Talent pouring
into Ai and so we can predict that
something is going to come out come out
of that you have lots of interesting
insights about information Theory and
how this can help us predict uh AI
what's the most important lessons from
information Theory the reason I I start
there is because sort of within the con
conceptual realm it's sort of like the
most General thing that bounds
everything else and when you look back
at the record of say you know Ray kurile
you know I I first read the age of
spiritual machines when I was a kid and
and you know in there makes a prediction
that we'll have AIS that pass the Turing
test by you know 2029 or so and when was
this book uh written 1999 yeah that's
pretty good right and so you know and he
got and people will complain that he got
things wrong because he said well I'll
be wearing AR glasses by
2019 uh you know when in fact like
Google Glass came out in 2013 and and
now we have meta glasses 5 years later
um so he he was like wrong on the exact
timing but sort of Right Where the
technology was wrong where the minimum
viable product was but nonetheless like
if you look at his track record it's
it's quite good for a methodology as as
relatively stupid as just staring at
Mo's law and extrapolating it out and I
think that reveals the the power of
these information theoretic
methodologies to forecasting because
they they set bounds on what will be
possible the team at EPO AI have a uh a
forecast called the direct approach
where is sort of you can think of it
sort of like a way of putting bounds on
when we'll have AIS that can emulate
Human Performance through an information
theoretic lens where they're looking at
sort of how much entropy does the brain
sort of process and how much compute
will we have over time and what what's
implied by AI scaling laws you sort of
put those three things together and you
can sort of set bounds on when we'll
basically be able to Brute Force human
level um intelligence and and of of
course that's an upper bound because
we're going to do better than Brute
Force we're going to also have insights
from uh cognitive science neuroscience
and also uh you know ways of distilling
neural networks and so forth and better
ways of curating data so their modal
estimate for human level AI is is
2029 um and their meeting is like 2036
and um I've talked to the authors and
and they lean lean towards the 2029 2030
for their own um personal forecasts and
you so going back to you know is is this
an outlier I am I out on a limb here I
think among our circles probably not but
among Congress and among the broader
public I think people are seeing sort of
they they think everything's an ASM
toote right they they're imagining okay
we have these chat Bots and they not
seeing the next step you know I see a
very smooth path from here to systems
that can basically in context learn any
arbitrary human human task and so what
does that look like it looks like
systems that can basically sit over your
shoulder or can monitor your desktop
your operating system as you work and uh
you know watch you for an hour or two
and then take over and that will be key
to overcoming lack of training data or
why is why is it important that they can
learn in context uh well in context
learning is is um sort of the secret
source of the power of Transformer
models they learn these inductive biases
induction heads and so forth that let
them you few shot learn different tasks
so so you know gp4 is very good at zero
zero shot learning on on a variety of
different things but it's it's
incredibly good few shot learning if you
give it a few examples it can kind of
pick up where you left off you know when
I think about myself when I want to
learn a new recipe right I can go read a
recipe book but often what I I prefer to
do is to go on YouTube and watch someone
make that
recipe right and and just by watching
that person put together the stir fry I
have enough of a world model and and
enough of knowledge of how to cook in
general that uh I can sort of in context
learn um how to pick up from there and
do that recipe myself llms do that
already multimodal models are increasing
doing that um some of the recent
progress in in robotics uh like I
mentioned the Q Q Transformer paper it
shows that you can basically build
robots with a basic World model and then
have it learn new tasks with fewer than
100 examples of a human demonstration so
the human sort of demonstrates the task
and the robot uh can pick it up and and
take it from there and why that's
important is is both for understanding
the trajectory of AI but also its
economic implementation because we sort
of used to automation being this thing
where you get a contract from IBM and
you spend uh many millions of dollars
within consultants and they build you
some bespoke thing that doesn't really
work very well um and requires lots of
Maintenance and so people have the this
sort of Prior that AI even if it even if
it's near will be rate limited by the
real world because of all the complexity
of implementation but the point is if
you have things that can in context
learn and and perform sort of as humans
perform then you don't need to change
the process you can take human designed
processes and have the AI just fill fill
in for the human and so it leads to this
Paradox where we're probably going to
have AGI before we get rid of the last
fax
machine yeah when we think of say old it
systems in large institutions we we
might think of moving from from analog
um storage of of information to to the
cloud that that's still going on in some
institutions that information has taken
over a decade now and so what exactly is
it that that makes AI different here it
is that that AI plugs in directly where
the human worker would be yeah precisely
you don't you don't need to um you
redesign existing process to sort of
plug into the Automation and that that
applies both for sort of the structure
of tasks right like so much of a
mechanical automation takes something
like U the sort of artisinal work of a
of a um of a Shoemaker and has to
translate it into something repetitive
that a machine or an automatic
seamstress can uh can do over and over
and over over again our older School
kind of automation requires sort of
collapsing a task into lower Dimension
so that so that um so that simple
automations can handle it but when you
have AGI the whole point is generality
it's a
flexible uh intelligence that can map to
existing kinds of processes so that
that's that's sort of why I think this
will catch people by surprise because
it's not just it's not just that AGI
could be this decade but that when it
arrives and sort of crosses some
thresholds of reliability the
implementation frictions could be very
low and do you expect would AI have to
get all the way there in order to
substitute for for a human worker I mean
I would expect it to be a bit more
gradual than that taking over say 20% of
tasks before 40% of tasks 60% of tasks
and so on but but here we're imagining
that the AI kind of plugs in for the
human worker for all tasks or what do
you have in mind these things are yeah
you're right much more continuous it's
not it's not an on or off switch um in
part because the the the requisite
threshold of reliability varies by the
type of task you know arguably
self-driving cars like weo or Tesla have
matched Human Performance but Regulators
want them to be 100x better than human
before before they they're let let loose
on the road because of safety you know
codec and coding models are arguably
still much worse today than Elite
programmers but everyone is using them
because even if it generates 50% of your
code and you have to go back in and
debug it's still a huge productivity
boost so I think it will vary by by
occupation by by sort of task category
sort of modulo the risks and and Stakes
involved in those uh in those tasks yeah
I guess then the question is how many of
our jobs fall into the is more like
self-driving cars and how how many many
of a jobs is more like programming right
I I mean um I've been in a manager
position before and I've had research
assistants and interns and I know that
they're like a a very lossy compression
of of the thing I want to do and so they
do require oversight and sort of
co-piloting we're sort of in that stage
now with AIS and a variety of different
times of kinds of tasks you know I
recently read a paper compar um
evaluating the use of gp4 for peer
review in science and it found that uh
uh gp4 would write reviews of work that
bore some striking correlations with
with with the points raised by human
reviewers but also left some things out
and so it conclud it by saying gb4 you
know could be a you know invaluable tool
for scientific review but it's not it's
not about to replace people and I that's
just a case of like okay give it five
years yeah this is this is a phenomena
you often see with with with um some AI
models out there and it has some
capabilities but lacks other
capabilities and then people might kind
of over anchor on the present
capabilities and not foresee the the way
the development is going I think people
are continually surprised at at the
advancement of AI yeah absolutely you
know RZ n um the uh the Sci-Fi author
and futurist energy investor he he he
gives us talk on solar energy and and
other Renewables and he and he has this
famous graph where he shows the
International Energy um agency the Ia
every year they put out this projection
of solar uh buildout and every year it's
like a flatline but it's like a flat
line on an exponential like the real
curve is like going vertical and every
year their projection is that it's just
going to plateau and I feel like um
people make that same mistake and and it
sort of has this sort of a ironic lesson
you know to the extent that uh we're
drawing sort of parallels with the way
our brain works and the way these models
work it seems like humans have a very
strong autor regressive bias so so
what's going on there is it is it an
Institutional problem or is it is it a
psychological problem why is it that we
can't um project correctly in many
cases well to what I just said I think
it's it's probably both but largely
psychological right our brains are
evolved for you know 100 gather
societies that didn't really change over
Millennia and uh you know even the last
40 50 years have been a period of
relative stagnation where we have a lot
of sort of pseudo Innovation and so I
think people are just a bit uh sort
disabused okay you you have some super
interesting points about the comparing
the human brain how the human brain
works to how neural networks uh learn
what is universality in uh in the
context of of brain learning and neural
network learning so universality is a
term of art it sort of refers to the
fact that different neural networks
independently trained you know even on
different data uh will often Converge on
very similar uh representations in in
their embedding space of that data and
you can extend that to striking
parallels or is isomorphisms between the
representations that neural n artificial
neural networks learn and that our brain
appears to learn probably the area of
the brain that's been studied the most
is the visual CeX and it seems to me as
like a lay person that the the broad
consensus in Neuroscience is that the
visual cortex is very similar to a deep
convolutional neural network is
basically isomorphic to our our
artificial deep convolutional neur
neural networks and you train uh CCN on
image data and our brain is trained on
our sensory data um and it turns out
they end up learning striking the
similar
representations um and there are a few
reasons for that right so you know one
is sort of um
hierarchies of abstraction it it makes
sense that early layers in a neural
network will learn things like edges and
and simple shapes and only later in the
only deeper in the network will you
learn more subtle features so there's
that sort of sequencing uh part of it
and then there's also just the energy
constraint you know gradient descent
isn't Costless right it requires energy
it requires a lot of energy that's you
know these data centers suck up a lot of
energy um the same is true of our brain
you know our brain consumes a lot of uh
energy like 25 % of her calories and
especially when it's in in in When We're
Young there's a very strong met
metabolic cost associated with
neuroplasticity our brain being
something shaped by Evolution was
obviously very energy conscious and so
those energy constraints greatly shrink
the landscape of possible
representations from sort of this
infinite landscape of all the ways you
could represent certain data to a a much
more manageable set of representations
and that doesn't guarantee that we'll
converge on the same represent ations at
least suggestive of a of of a weak
universality where uh even when we don't
have the exact same representations
they're often a coordinate
transformation away from each other yeah
it's actually a bit surprising to me you
as you mentioned uh when we train neural
networks we don't have the same energy
constraints as the as the brain had
during our Evolution and I would expect
again from Evolution the human brains
who have many more inbuilt biases and
heuristics uh but if we then comp
compare the the representations in a in
a neural network to to the those in a
human brain we found that they are quite
similar is isn't that the whole point of
of universality so does the neural
network um have the same charistics and
biases that we have or what's going on
here well one of the primary you know
biases in stochastic gradient descent is
uh sometimes called a Simplicity
preference basically an inductive bias
for more parsimonious representations
parsimonious and the sense of aam's
Razer right and that's that's a
byproduct of this uh information
theoretic concept of colog complexity um
where colog complexity means is measured
by you know uh is there a short program
that can reproduce this longer sequence
and if you can find a short program
that's sort of a more compact or more
compressed way of representing it and
when you're under energy constraints
you're looking for those more compressed
representations um and so that
Simplicity bias seems to be also the
origin of generalization of her ability
to to go beyond merely memorizing data
overfitting our parameters to finding a
simpler way of representing those
parameters right where we go from sort
of fitting a bunch of data points to
recognizing oh these data points are
being generated by a sign function so I
can replace all these these data points
by a simple circuit for that sign
function or something like that what can
we learn about AI progress when we
consider the hard steps that humans and
our ancestors have gone through in in
evolution it Beyond Evolution um this is
often comes up in the discussion of the
fmy Paradox uh life on Earth to exist at
all let alone intelligent life had to
pass through many hard steps right we
had to have a planet in a habitable zone
we had to have uh you know the the right
mix of organic chemicals um in the
Earth's crust and so forth we have to
have the conditions for abiogenesis the
emergence of the the very earliest sort
of non-living replicators probably you
know some kind of polymer type of
crystal structure then we had to have
you know the transition from single cell
to multicellular organisms to transition
through the campan explosion right all
all every one of these steps you could
think of as a very unlikely improbable
thing all the way up to you know the
development of warm-blooded mammals and
uh sort of uh social animals that were
were heavily selected for for brain size
to to then the social cultural hard
steps of like moving from small group
primates to to sort of settled
technological uh cultures than you know
technological hard steps like the
discovery of the printing press or the
discovery of the
transistor you put those all together
and life seems just incredibly unlikely
and you know this often goes to the the
the point of view that you know cre
or or intelligent designers would would
put forward but then you zoom out and
then you recognize oh wait there are you
know trillions of galaxies each with
trillion you know hundreds of billions
of stars and hundreds hundreds billions
of trillions of planets there's a
there's an awful
lot of U potential variation out there
and and then meanwhile every one of
these hard steps seems characterized by
a search problem that is very hard but
then once you find the correct thing
like the earliest self-replicator um
things kind of take off right so you
imagine that before the earliest
self-replicator there were millions or
or billions of attempts to to
self-replicate like that that didn't
succeed yeah it's just a huge search
problem right and you know maybe there
are more gradual intermediate stages
where you have sort of uh you know
everything in biology ends up looking
way more gradual the more you learn
about it but there are these face
transitions where you tip over and you
get the camine explosion or you get the
printing press and the printing
Revolution and so those hard steps end
up looking relatively look they look
more easy in retrospect uh because even
though the search was hard once you once
You' tripped over the correct solution
there's sort of an autocatalytic
self-reinforcing Loop that pulls you
into a new regime and indeed when you
look at the emergence of life on Earth
relative to the age of the Universe um
and OB with some uh co-authors have done
this life on Earth is incredibly early
like you know the universe is 13.7
billion years old but life couldn't
emerge uh really much sooner the reason
being the you know the universe started
out as hot and dense had to cool down uh
Stars had to form those Stars had to
Supernova so they could produce the
heavy heavy elements that um that are
Central to life and then those solar
systems had to then take shape uh and
then then had to further cool so the
solar system wasn't being you know
irradiated constantly um and when you
put all those factors together human
life emerged basically as soon as it was
possible for life to emerge anywhere and
so this this is one way to answer the
fmy Paradox is that we're just in the
first cohort right but it also should
give you strong priors that passing
through those hard steps isn't as hard
as it looks and what's the lesson for AI
here developing AGI is is sort of a hard
step uh where doing this kind of uh
gradient search for the right algorithms
for the right uh what have you um and we
seem to be now in a slow takeoff where
we've figured out the core ingredients
and there's now an autocatalytic process
that's pulling us into a new phase and
what do you mean by autocatalytic self-
reinforcing um you know once it once it
gets started it it it sort of pulls
itself it sort of has an as if tileology
right you see this in nature but you
also see this in you know in
capitalism and you would expect us to
get to Advanced AI basically as soon as
it's computationally
possible it it it basically seemed that
way right like you know there was a kind
of tacit collusion between Google and
and other players in the space to you
know they had Transformer models since
2017 but really you know there's some of
the precursors to Transformers go back
to the early 90s but you know once you
have this sort of profit opportunity
that's that's in the background it's
hard in a competitive environment to
stop an open AI from being like Oh Let's
uh let's chase those profits um and then
once that ball gets rolling it's
basically impossible to stop this is
this is why you know whatever the merits
of the pause letter it it's virtually
impossible to to to really have a pause
in AI development because because
everything is is uh sort of structured
by these game theoretic uh incentives to
just keep going faster once you've
stumbled on the gold Reserve uh it's
hard to keep the uh the Prospectors from
running there Samuel is the US
government prepared for advanced Ai
No uh no I mean um where do I start I
mean the US government's
in if you think of it from a firmware
level you know many countries have
National IDs the US doesn't have a
national ID we have social security
numbers these like nine-digit numbers
that date back to
1935 we have uh uh the core
administrative laws date back to the
early' 40s you know much of our sort of
technical infrastructure like the the uh
the system the IRS runs on uh date back
to the Kennedy administration and are
written in assembly code there's also
been this General decline in what you
could call State capacity sort of the
ability for US government to um execute
on things and you hear about this all
the time you hear about how you know the
the Golden Gate Bridge was built in four
years or something like that uh and now
it takes like 10 years to build an
access road one of the reasons for that
goes to what uh the the legal scholar
Nicholas Bagley is called the procedural
fetish really since the 70s the
Machinery of the US government has
shifted towards a Reliance on explicit
process right and
proceduralism has pluses and minuses if
you have a a clear process government
can kind of run on a autopilot to an
extent but it also means you limit the
room for discretion and you limit the
flexibility of government to move
quickly and moreover in our adversarial
legal system you also open up avenues
for sort of continuous judicial review
and legal challenge where um you know
famously New York uh has taken over
three years to approve uh congestion
pricing on one of their Bridges because
because has to undergo environmental
review and people who don't want to pay
the congestion price keep suing do you
think having more procedures would make
it easier for AI to interface with with
the with government I would say having
fewer procedures would make it easier
for government to adapt my assumption
would be that that having something
written down having a procedure for
something would make it easier for for a
to to plug AI into that procedure if
it's if it's less opaque and and more
kind of a almost like an algorithm step
by step yes um but the you know the
analogy I would give is to you know the
Manhattan Project right the manhatt the
the original Manhattan Project was run
like a startup you had uh Oppenheimer
and general Les grow sort of being the
the technical founder and the uh the you
know typ a get things done founder and
you know they broke all the rules they
they you know push pushed as hard as
they could they were managing at at its
peak like 100,000 people in secret and
they built the nuclear bomb in in three
years right and so the way we would do
that today under procedural fetish
framework would be to put out a bunch of
requests for proposals and uh have some
kind of uh competitive
bid and and then we'd probably get like
the lowest cost bid and it would be like
lockie Martin and they would um uh you
know build half an atom bomb and it
would take 20 years and uh five times
the budget um and so so that that's sort
of what I'm getting at it's not it's not
about uh process versus discretion per
se it's about the way process process
hobbles and straight jackets our ability
to adapt and sort of represents a kind
of sclerosis a kind of sort of like
crystallized intelligence we we we lay
down the things that worked in the past
as process and sort of freeze those
processes in place
aify um a particular modality right and
when the when the motor production
shifts and you need to completely tear
up that process root and Branch it's
it's very difficult because often
there's no process for changing the
process yeah I I I wonder if if there
are lessons for how government will
respond to Ai and thinking about how
governments responded to to say
historical Technical Innovations of of
the similar magnitude uh like the
Industrial Revolution or the the
printing press or maybe the internet
computer do you think we can draw
General lessons or is it is it uh so
specific that we can't really extract
information about the future from them I
think they're very powerful General
lessons you know I think one of the
first general lessons is that every
major technological uh transformation in
human history has has preceded a
institutional transformation you know
whether it's the shift from nomadic to
to settled city states with the
Agricultural Revolution or um you know
the rise of Modern Nation States or the
the end of feudalism with with the
printing press to you know in the New
Deal era the sort of transition with
industrialization from the kind of lasir
classical liberal phase of um 18th
century America to to an America with a
robust welfare state and administrative
bureaucracies um and really an all an
all new constitutional order right and
so there's sort of better and worse ways
for this transition to happen there's
there's sort of the internal regime
change model and you can think of you
know Abraham Lincoln or or FDR as
inaugurating a new Republic a new
American republic or there's a scenario
where we don't change because we're too
crystallized and sort of like an
innovators dilemma get displaced by some
new upart and there different countries
have different abilities and different
sort of capacities for that that
internal adaptation um as a Canadian I'm
a big fan of like Westminster style
parliamentary systems and one of the
reasons is because it's very easy for
parliamentary systems to shut down
Ministries open up new Ministries to re
reorganize the civil service because
it's it's sort of vertically integrated
under the prime minister's office or
what have you um in the US it's it's
much worse because given the separation
of powers you know Congress and the
executive are uh often not working well
together just to put it just to to as an
understatement but then moreover the
different federal agencies uh have it
sort of a life of their own often
they're you know self-funded and all
these other things that make it very
difficult to reform do you think Canada
responded better to to the rise of the
internet than the US for example is
there something wrong with the story
because the US kind of birthed the
internet and Canada you know adopted the
internet from from the US let's compare
first of all uh the the impact of the
internet on on weaker States because you
know Canada and the US are are similar
or sort of in in in one quadrant um they
have differences but the differences are
small compared to other countries if you
think about like Internet safety
discussions that would have been taking
place in the early 2000s people would
have been talking about you know
identity theft credit card theft child
exploitation um these kind of like
direct first order potential harms from
the internet they didn't foresee that
concurrent with the rise of of mobile um
in social media that the internet would
enable tools for Mass mobilization
simultaneous with a kind of legitimacy
crisis where the sort of new
transparency um and information um
access that the internet provided eroded
trust in government and Trust in other
institutions so you have these two two
forces interacting the internet exposing
government and exposing corruption and
leading to a decline in trust while also
creating a platform for people to rise
up and mobilize against against that
corruption right and it's something that
that kind of rhymes with the printing
press and the printing Revolution where
you had these sort of um dormant
suppressed minority groups like the
Puritans or the Presbyterians the
non-conformists and with the with the
collapse of the censorship printing
licensing regime they actually the
licensing regime in in in in the UK
Parliament uh back Circa 1630 um uh that
licensing regime collapsed I think 1634
or something around there and that that
uh was like five years before the
English Civil War and you see something
like this in the Arab Spring where the
internet quite directly led to mass
mobilization in Cairo and Tunisia and
elsewhere um and led to actual regime
change in some cases sort of temporary
State collapse and that's because those
were weaker states that hadn't
democratized that hadn't sort of had
their own information
revolution earlier in their history the
way we did right in some ways like the
American Republic is sort of a Founder
country built on the backbone of the
printing Revolution so we were we were a
little bit
more robust to that because it's sort of
part of our ethos to have this open uh
disagreeable Society but clearly it's
ALS the internet has also affected the
legitimacy of Western democracies I
think it's clear clearly one of the
major inputs in sort of rising populism
the mass mobilizations that we we see
whether in the US context the the 2020
uh you know racial Awakening or or the
January 6th uh sort of peasant Rebellion
right these these look these these sort
of look like the kind of color
revolutions that we see abroad and you
know some people want to ascribe
conspiracy theories to that I I think
there's a simpler explanation which is
which is that people will self organize
with the right tools our state hasn't
collapsed yet but it's clearly it
there's clearly a lot of um a lot of
cracks in the foundation if you will is
would it be fair to say that the main
lesson for you from history is that
technological change brings
institutional change yeah you know not
not necessarily one for one I'm not I'm
not kind of a vulgar Marxist on this but
uh but yes and and the reason for that
is because institutions themselves exist
due to a certain cost structure
and if you have general purpose
technologies that that dramatically
change that the the nature of that cost
structure then institutional change will
follow yeah and I think we want to get
to that but before we do I think we
should discuss ai's impact on the the
broader economy so so not just the
government but but the economy in
general economists have this fallacy
they they um they point out often the
Lum of Labor fallacy maybe you could
explain that the lump of Labor fallacy
is essentially the idea that there's a
fixed amount of work to be done if you
were
thinking about the Industrial Revolution
and what would happen to the 50% of
people who are in agriculture you you
couldn't imagine the new jobs that would
be created but new jobs were created and
the reason is because human wants are
infinite and and so you know demand will
always fill
Supply uh the second reason is because
there's a kind of circular flow in the
economy where one person's cost is
another person's income society would
collapse if we had true technological
unemployment because there' be things
being produced but no one to pay for
them and so that ends up kind of
bootstrapping new Industries and new
sources of of production there there's
still this open question is like is this
time different yeah that's what I that
is that's exactly what I want to know
because I mean for me it's it's or in
retrospect let's say it's it's easy to
see how how workers could move from from
fields to to factories into into offices
but if we have truly General AI it's
it's difficult for me to see where
workers would move especially if we have
also
functional robots and perhaps AIS that
are better at uh taking care of people
than than than other people are U I'm
not asking you to predict specific jobs
but I'm asking you whether whether you
think this historical Trend will hold
with the Advent of advanced AI you know
the first first thing to say is you know
when K's wrote um economic possibilities
for our grandchildren uh famous text
where he predicted that technological
progress would lead to uh the growth of
of a Leisure society and this was in the
1930s yeah uh you know people have
dismissed him as being wrong um but
actually you look at time use data and
employment data and people are working
less you know it's it's not it it didn't
match his the the optimism of his
projection right because uh it turns out
you know maybe maybe if we fixed living
standards at at what he expected it
people people want more and people work
more for more but overall people are
working less people do have more Leisure
we we've sort of moved to a de facto
4day work week so there's there's one
world where rapid technological progress
sort of continues that Trend and we all
work less is sort of a technological
unemployment that's spread across people
and is is is enabled in part because in
a world of AGI maybe you only have to
work you know a few hours a day to you
know make $100,000 a year there's
another another uh possibility which is
that while AGI could in principle be a
perfect emulation of humans on specific
tasks it can't emulate the historical
formation of that person right so what I
mean by that is if you had a perfect
atom by atom replication of the Mona
Lisa it wouldn't sell at
auction right because people aren't just
buying the physical substrate they're
also buying the kind of world
line of of that thing and and that's
clearly the case in humans as well like
there there are certain you know Talking
Heads that I go and and enjoy not
because they are the smartest or or what
have you because I I'm interested in
what that person thinks on this um
because they have a particular
personality particular World line and
then the third factor is uh sort of um
artificial scarcity right and so even in
a world with with um with abundance and
Supply uh in services and goods there
are still things that will be
intrinsically scarce uh real estate
being being probably the E canonical
thing but also energy and commodities
and so forth and the reason real estate
is intrinsically scarce just because
people you know want to live near other
people and and people want to live in uh
particular areas of a city you know they
want to live in the the Posh part of
town right and those are POS positional
Goods we can't all live in the the
trendy Loft so that builds into kind of
artificial scarcity and so people will
still be competing over those things
this is sort of related to artificial
scarcity but there's also sort of break
it out into a fourth possibility which
are which are sort of tournaments and
things that are structured as
tournaments having chess spots that are
strictly better than humans at chess uh
hasn't killed you know people playing
chess if anything uh more people play
chess today than have had in human
history yeah it's more popular than ever
yeah and the reason is because people
like to watch other humans playing and
also it's they're structured as as sort
Zero Sum tournaments where there can
only be the best human you look at other
things that have been created just in
the last 15 20 years the the X Games
right you know I I think people will
still want to watch other people do the
Olympics or or do Motocross and all
these other things and so maybe more of
our life shifts into you know both um
maybe greater Leisure on the one hand
more competition over uh positional
Goods and more um more production that
is structured as a tournament yeah yeah
I can see many of those points I'm just
thinking again with with fully General
AI you would be able to to generate a a
much more interesting person uh playing
chess or at least a simulation of a of a
very charismatic and interesting human
chess player why wouldn't people watch
that chess player uh as opposed to to
the most to the the best human um maybe
they will it's hard hard to know uh the
question is who's producing that that
video stream because U you still need
the human behind it that's that had the
idea right and um you could imagine
people being dishonest about the history
of of this chess player this this
simulated chess player could could be
fully fully digital fully fully
fictional so to speak and just
pretending to be human right so it could
fool people um that's that's the case
too no I I can't rule that out but I
would just say that um however that
person is monetizing they're um deep
fake chess player they're making money
which they're then spending back into
the economy and so they'll produce jobs
somewhere do you think more people will
move into say people focused Industries
like nursing and and teaching is that is
that a possible way for for for us to to
maintain jobs maybe nursing at least in
the short run um I'm not very long on
education being being uh labor intensive
for much longer but but you don't think
education is at at least say say grade
school education is is that really about
teaching people or conveying knowledge
or or to what extent is is it about
conveying knowledge and to what extent
is it about the social interaction and
you know uh specializing your your
teaching to to the individual student
well AI are very good at uh
customization and sort of Master tuty
education is a bundle of things and you
know you for younger ages it's it's also
daycare it is socialization like you
said at the very least it mean it it
suggests a reor reorganization of the
division of labor because the types of
teachers that you would select hire for
May differ if the education component of
that bundle is being done by AI you know
maybe you select for people who are
maybe don't have any subject matter
expertise but are just highly
conscientious and and good around kids
or maybe you un bundle from public
education altogether and and it rebundle
around you know a jitu school or or
chess Academy because you know you'll
have the AI tutor that will teach you
math but you'll still want to Grapple
with the human yeah yeah what about
Industries with occupational licensing
like uh like law or medicine will they
be able to to keep up their quite High
wages in the face of AI being able to
you know be a pretty good doctor and a
pretty good lawyer it's easy to solve
for the far you know long-term
equilibrium uh with the rise of the
internet you can do a comparison of the
the wage distribution for lawyers pre-
and post internet and you know Circuit
of the early 90s uh lawyer lawyer
incomes were normally distributed around
$60,000 a year you know after in the
2000s uh they become bodal um and so you
have one mode that's still around that
$60,000 range that's like the family
lawyers and then you have this other
mode that's that into the six figures
and those are like big law right it's
the emergence of these law firms where
you have a few Partners on top and maybe
hundreds of uh of Associates who are
doing kind of Grant work using westla
and Lexus Nexus and these other uh legal
search engines to um accelerate Drafting
and and uh legal analysis so if that
pattern repeats I could imagine these
various uh you know High skill uh
knowledge sectors to also become bodal
where in the short run AI serves as a
co-pilot sort of like Westlaw or Lexus
Nexus was for for legal research and
enables the kind of 100x lawyer and uh
and so there's a kind of averages over
Dynamic longer
run you know you start to see the
possibility of doing an end run around
existing um accreditation and Licensing
monopolies where you know obviously the
medical American Medical Association and
medical boards will be highly resistant
to an AI doctor you know I tend to think
that they'll probably end up self-c
cannibalizing because the uh value prop
is so great even even you know for
doctors to you know do simple things
like automate uh insurance paper work
and stuff like that but to the extent
that there is a resistance to the extent
that you know in 10 years there's still
a requirement that you must you know
have the doctor prescribe the treatment
or refer you to a specialist even if
even though the AI is doing all the work
and they're just sort of of like the
elevator person that's like actually
just pushing the button for you it'll be
very easy to to en run that because AI
is both transforming the task itself but
also transforming its the means of
distribution and if you can go to gp4
and ask for put in your blood work and
get a
diagnosis that no regulator is going to
stop that right and so you know gp4
becomes sort of the ultimate Doctor of
borders you write a lot about
transaction costs and how changes in
transaction costs change institutional
structures first of all what are
transaction costs and and how do you
think they'll be affected by AI so
transaction cost is sort of an umbrella
term for different kinds of costs
associated with market exchange and this
goes back to Ronald CO's famous paper on
the theory of the firm where he asked
the question you know why do we have
corporations in the first place if free
markets are so great why don't we just
uh go and spot contract for everything
and the answer is well market exchange
itself has a cost there's the cost of
monitoring you know if you hire a
contractor you don't know exactly what
they're doing uh there's the cost of
bargaining you know um you know having
to hegle with a taxi cab driver is a is
a friction and there's the cost of
search associative search and
information so taking those three things
together they're not all that companies
do but they're they they structure the
boundary of the corporation they explain
why some things are done inhouse and
some things are done through contracts
if if there's High monitoring cost you
want to pull that part of the production
into the company so that you can monitor
the and manage the people doing the
production and some of the same effects
go for the existence of governments
right yes because governments you know
with a certain gal governments and
corporations aren't that different they
kinds of institutional structures that
pull certain things inhouse and certain
things are left uh for Contracting or or
outsourced and you know you even see
sort of different kinds of governments
having different parallels with
different kinds of corporate governance
right relatively egalitarian Democratic
societies like Denmark are kind of like
Mutual
insurers uh whereas more hierarchical
authoritarian countries are more like uh
you know like Singapore say is more is
more of a joint stock Corporation and
indeed you know Singapore was founded as
a as a entot for the East India Company
so there are very deep parallels and
it's also Al essential transaction costs
are essential L to understand why
governments do certain things and not
other things all Western developed
governments guarantee some amount of
basic health healthare right but
um most you know outside of say the
national heal Health Service and in the
UK most of these countries uh guarantee
the insurance they don't necessarily
nationalize the actual providers right
um and the reason goes to transaction
costs and and sort of an analysis of the
market failure Insurance likewise with
roads uh you know it's possible to build
roads through P purely private means and
indeed um you know countries like Sweden
a lot of the roads are run by private
associations but uh if you have lots of
different boundaries different jur micro
jurisdictions and so forth there can be
huge transaction costs to uh to
negotiating up to to a um interstate
highway system um and and those
transaction costs then NE necessitate
public infrastructure projects so the
transaction cost in this case would be
being a a a private road provider you'd
have to go negotiate with 500 different
land owners about building a highway
whereas a government can do some
expropriation and and simply build the
the road much much faster or with less
transaction costs at least yeah
precisely and we're seeing this this
dynamic in the US with uh you know
permitting for for grid grid
infrastructure and transmission you know
we we're building all the all the solar
and renewable energy but to build the
actual transmission infrastructure to
get the electrons from where it's sunny
to where where it's cold requires
building you know high voltage uh lines
across state lines across different grid
regions and there are all kinds of nimes
and negotiation costs involved holdouts
and so forth and so that the more those
kind of costs exist the more it
militates towards a kind of um larger
scale intervention that you know
federalized
that process yeah the big question then
is how will AI change these transaction
costs what will the effects be here it's
easy to say that they will be
affected and you know obviously the
internet affected them to to an extent
and we were talking we talk about sort
of the ease of mobilizing uh protest
movements or the kind of U the the
sunlight that was put on government
corruption those are those are
reflecting declines in the cost
associate of information and cour
coordination I think AI takes us to
another level and I think it's it's
important to to Think Through in part
because right now the AI safety debate
at least in the United States is very
polarized between people who who are
like everything's going to be great and
people who are like this is like a
Terminator scenario or an AI kill us all
existential risk you know even if we
accept the you know existential risk
framing there's still going to be many
intermediate stages of AI before we flip
on the super intelligence and those
intermediate stages have enormous
implications for the structure of the
very institutions that will need to
respond to Super intelligence or what
have you the ways we can see this is
because all these information and and
monitoring and and uh bargaining costs
are directly implicated by commoditized
intelligence you know start with the
principal agent problem you know there
is no principal agent problem if your
agent does exactly as you ask and works
24/7 doesn't steal from the till right
and so AI agents dramatically collapse
agency cost monitoring now that we have
multimodal models in principle we could
have cameras in every house that are
just being prompted to say you know is
someone committing a crime right
now uh whether we want to go that
direction or not um it gives you a sense
that of how you know the cost of
monitoring have basically plummeted over
the last two years and are are going to
go lower and So you you're starting to
see this roll out in the private sector
with um you know Activision has
announced that they're going to be using
language models for um moderating voice
chat in Call of Duty right and and this
this is a more robust form of monitoring
because in the past you would have to
like ban certain words like certain
swear words or or um things associate
with sex or violence um but then people
could always get around those by using
euphemisms right uh like on YouTube you
know the algorithm will ding you if you
talk about Corona virus or if you talk
about murder or suicide these these
things that that throw off red flags so
what people have taken doing is saying
um they were un alived rather than
murdered right and that doesn't fool a
language model if you ask a language
model you know if you prompt it in a way
to look for sort of broad semantic
categories not just a narrow a narrow
word it's much more robust and so what
that means you know what that you
already start to see it like I said with
Activision and and the use of llms and
content moderation you're going to start
you're going to see it in the use of uh
multimodal models for for productivity
management and tracking you know
Microsoft is unveiling their 365
co-pilot where you know you're going to
have gp4 in Word and Excel and teams and
Outlook but at the same time you're also
going to have a manager who's going to
be able to say you know to prompt the
model tell me who's the most productive
this week right something as vague as
that and so you see this diffusion in
the private sector the question is does
it diffuse in the public sector there's
obvious ways that it would be a huge
boom right you know Inspector General
GPT could tell you exactly you know how
how the civil service is is working
whether there's corruption whether
there's a deep state conspiracy or
something like that right and at first
blush a lot of what government does is
kind of a flushy API bureaucracies are
nodes that apply a a degree of context
between printing out a PDF and scanning
it back into the computer it varies
there's degrees of uh of human judgment
that are required but on first order
government bureaucracies seem incredibly
exposed to this technology um and in a
way that could diffuse really rapidly
because you know going back to Microsoft
365 co-pilot Microsoft is the biggest it
vendor in US Government right and so you
can imagine once uh everyone has this
pre-installed on their computer that the
person at the Bureau of Labor Statistics
who's in charge of doing the monthly
uh employment situation report the job
the jobs report you know at some point
he's going to be walking into work and
hitting a button right that you know
asking uh Excel to find the five most
interesting Trends and generate charts
and the report is done and in the
private sector that person would be
reallocated and maybe doing things that
the computer's not good at yet uh but
these uh these positions are much
stickier in government to the extent
that diffusion is inhibited on the
public sector side I worry about the
kind of disruption and displacement of
of government services by a private
sector that's that's adopting the
technology really fast this is something
we we'll talk about in a moment before
that I just want to get to um your
complaints about isolated thinking about
AI youve you've you've sketched out some
uh some complaint about people thinking
about uh AI only applying to one domain
and then not really seeing the bigger
picture what what are some examples here
why do you worry about isolated thinking
few a few Dimensions to this one is what
I've called the Horseless Carriage
fallacy right the kind of view that you
know what automobiles were was just a a
carriage with the horse right and so
that that anchors you to the older
Paradigm and it's like you're changing
one thing and everything else stays the
same and you neglect all the second
order ways that the development of the
automobile you know enabled the buildout
of Highway systems the the total
reconfiguration of sort of the economic
geography right and then implication for
institions like the state where you know
once you have Road networks or Telegraph
networks or any of these these kind of
networks it suddenly becomes easier to
monitor um agents of the state and other
parts of the country so you can you know
build out more of a federal bureaucracy
and so all these things were second
order and we kind of neglected if you
just were too focused on on the first
order effects of displacing the horses
and in a sense the the the second order
effects turned out to be much more
consequential in the end yes it seem to
always be and likewise with the internet
and sort of
the I think this comes up a lot in the
in in how to think about AI use and
misuse there's lots of valid discussions
there but they they're always very first
order and when you think about the way
the internet has disrupted Legacy
institutions yes there's disinformation
but often the thing that's disrupting is
not fake news it's real news that's
being repeated with with misleading
frequency right that's like throwing off
our availability hereis or or it's valid
things that um you know valid complaints
whether whether you know the protest in
Iran right the protest in Iran have this
like striking parallel to the protests
following the George Floyd protest um
and protest seen in other countries
where they even have like a three-word
chant right or the or the case of the um
Arab Spring in in in in Tunisia that
started with a person self- ulating
right there's sort of like the structure
that repeats where you have like a
martyr or like some some Shock event and
because of the way social media is
organized it synchronizes people around
that event um in a way that's kind of
stochastic like it's like lightning
striking you don't know what event is
going to strike on but once we're
synchronized then we start you know
moving back and forth in a in a way that
like causes the bridge to buckle nothing
about that is is is a misuse right those
are all valid uses but their their use
is under Collective action it's solving
not just for the partial equilibrium but
the general equilibrium when everyone is
doing this and and I think the person
who wrote the best on this sort of
conceptually was you know Thomas
shelling and one of his book little
books micro motives macro Behavior had a
big influence on me as a kid where he
you know he talks about all these sort
of like toy toy models where you're at a
a hockey game or a basketball game and
something is happening something
exciting is happening on the on the in
the arena and so people the people in
front of you stand up to get a better
View and then you have to stand up to
get a better view of them over them and
so on and so it Cascades and suddenly
everyone went from sitting to everyone
went to standing and no one's view has
improved right and so the these sort of
uh General equilibria where you sort of
solve for everyone's uh micro incentives
and and the kind of new Nash equilibrium
that emerges that ends up being the
thing that drives a kind of multi
multiple equilibrium shift from one
regime to another and and throughout
there there may be no actual examples of
misuse involved it may just be people
following following their their
individual incentives I think it's it's
worth stressing this point you make
about the effects of earlier AI systems
on our institutions they might have
effects that deteriorate our
institutions such that we can't handle
later and more advanced Ai and this
ignoring this would be an example of
isolated thinking and ignoring the
second order effects right yeah and they
also it also changes the the sort of um
agenda right the AI safety agenda
shouldn't just be about the first order
things or an alignment you know very
important but um you know it's led to a
discussion of do we need a new federal
agency and if so what kind of agency
whereas it may be more appropriate to
think not what new agency do we need but
how do all the agencies
change right and and how do we sort of
like brace for impact and and enable a
degree of um co-evolution rather than uh
displacement I don't know whether the
question whe the question of how to get
our institutions to respond
appropriately is more difficult or less
difficult than the problem of aligning
AI but it certainly seems very difficult
to me so is there are we making it
harder on ourselves if we focus on the
on the effects on the second order
effects on institutions I mean it's
unavoidable I mean we can't pick and
choose uh what kind of problems but um
you know the alignment problem the hard
version is yet to be solved uh but we
have many examples of governments
building State capacity and and having
kind of uh you know shifting from very
very like clientelistic sticky uh
corrupt governments to sort of modernize
governments where um you know State
capacity is built and then that then
that government can sort of break out of
the middle income trap and become rich
you mentioned Estonia as a as an example
of a of a country that's pretty advanced
on the it front on the technology side
maybe you could talk a bit about Estonia
yeah I would just say in general you
know it's hard for any organization to
reform itself from within when there is
path dependency but I I would say we at
least we have examples of it being done
uh where we don't have examples of
alignment being solved yet um when it
comes to Estonia you know Estonia is an
interesting case sort of an exception
exceptional case because after the fall
of the Soviet Union and the breakup of
the peripheral former Soviet States they
they kind of had a blank slate right um
they also had a very young population
and people who had a kind of hacker
ethic within their civil service and and
so with that blank slate and with that
hacker ethic they were very early to
adopt and and to foresee the way the
internet was going to shape government
through through a variety of
e-government reforms um so early in the
you know in the late 90s and into the
2000s they were some of the the earliest
to uh digitize their their uh banking
system like ebanking to uh build this uh
system called xroad which is kind of
like a cryptographically secured data
exchange layer it resembles a blockchain
but it was about a decade before
blockchain was invented for exchanging
information between different government
entities your medical information could
be uploaded to this to the system and
then be available to all systems that
have the the right to see that
information exactly in a way that's
cryptographically secured and
distributed so if a if a a missile will
hit the Department of Education you
don't lose your education records
because it's it's distributed uh and
that also enabled you know an enormous
amount of automation where uh for
instance this is my understanding a
child born in Estonia when once you file
that birth record it more or less
initiates a clock in the system that
will then then enroll your child in
school uh when they turn four or five
like automatically because it knows that
your child has has aged and unless it
had a death record to cancel out but it
also means you can you know do taxes and
transfers much simpler you get your get
your your benefit within a week you can
integrate across different different
parts of of uh public infrastructure
like you know use the same card to to uh
ride the bus as you do to to launch a
new business it also serves as a kind of
platform for uh the private sector to
sort of to do government by API right to
build new services on top of government
as a platform
and integrate with with government
databases yeah and so the point here for
us is that institutional reform is
possible modernizing government is
possible at least under certain
circumstances we have uh proofs of of
concepts of this happening the hard
thing is the path dependency there's
always a strong instinct to want to
start from scratch and it's it's
normally not advisable because because
just it's too hard and uh uh and so the
this is this is why it's hard in the US
like this is why you have African
countries that leap progress in payment
systems and so forth the the challenge
of this decade or century is how do we
solve that path dependency problem and
how do we get to Estonia it used to be
get to denark now it's now it's get to
get to Estonia um and find that sort of
U that pathway up Mountain probable
great let's uh let's get to your
wonderful series of of blog posts on AI
and Leviathan in this context what do we
mean by Leviathan well this all
interrelates so
um Leviathan was the book Hobbs Thomas
Hobbs wrote at the start of the internum
um after the English Civil War and it
was his basically his early political
science early defense of absolutist
monarchy as a way to in you know restore
peace and order after um after a decade
of uh
infighting and Hobbs kind of hit on some
basic sort of structural game theoretic
properties of you know why we have
governments at all right he talked about
life being nasty brtish and short in the
state of nature war of all against all
and peace is only restored when people
when people who don't trust each other
uh
offload uh enforcement and policing
responsibilities to to a higher power
that can then restore a degree of peace
and Order AI in Leviathan is talking
about you know how does AI change the
story does it reinforce the Leviathan
does it lead to a digital police state
out China or is it something that we
impose on ourselves and we talked about
how multimodal models could in principle
be used to uh put a camera in everyone's
house and have it just continuously
monitoring for people doing any kind of
crime that's something that North Korea
might do in in the US context it's
something that we're very liable to just
voluntarily do to ourselves because we
we want to have ring cameras and and
Alexa assistants and so forth and so
that leads to a kind of bottom up
Leviathan uh that is uh potentially no
less oppressive and maybe even more
oppressive because because it's it's
there's no one that we can appeal to to
change the rules yeah so Leviathan is
one way to respond to technological
change but you mentioned two other ways
we we could alternatively respond right
so so basically anytime a technology
greatly empowers the individual it it
create it creates a potential negative
externality right uh Hobs called These
are natural Liberties in the state of
nature I have a natural Liberty to to
kill you or to Strongarm you and uh
governments exist to revoke those
natural Liberties right but but for a
higher form of Freedom right and so
there're sort of anytime a technology
greatly increases human capabilities Vis
other humans the three canonical ways we
can adjust are you know seeding more
authority to that higher power the
Leviathan option and then the other two
options are you know adap a and
mitigation and and normative Evolution
so the example I give is is uh you know
if if suddenly we all add x-ray glasses
and could see through walls and see
through clothing you know one option
would we we have a a Draconian
totalitarian Crackdown uh that tries to
seize all those x-ray glasses another
option is we adjust normatively
culturally that we we uh our privacy
Norms wither away and we stop caring
about
nudity and then the other option is
adaptation mitigation where we we put in
you know mesh into our walls and and
wear uh wear leted Leed shirts and
pants yeah I guess continuing that
analogy a bit between the the the smart
glasses and AI um you you have this
amazing write up of of ways in which AI
can increase the informational
resolution of the universe so you give
some examples that are I'm I'm thinking
specifically of
identifying people by gate for example
right so so gate recognition is nothing
new China has um had Advanced forms of
gate recognition for a while now um so
you know even if you cover your face it
turns out we're constantly throwing off
sort of ambient information about
ourselves about about everything and the
way you walk the particular gate that
you have is a unique identifier uh the
another example is is is Galaxy surveys
uh there's we've had from hub telescope
now the jwst um you know tons of
astronomical surveys of you know distant
galaxies and so forth and all of a
sudden all that old data it's like it's
like that that same data set is now is
now more useful because applying more
modern deep learning techniques we can
extract entropy that was in that data
set but we didn't have the tools to
extract yet um and discover that you
know there are new galaxies or or or
other phenomena that we missed another
example you give is uh listening for for
keystrokes on a keyboard and extracting
information about a password being typed
in for example which is something that
of course humans can't do but but we can
do with with AI models yeah so that that
was a a paper showing that um you can
reconstruct keystrokes from an audio
recording including a zoom conversation
so I hope you haven't typed in your
password because people in the future
and so this goes to you know the fact
that it's sort of retroactive that like
even if the technology wasn't diffused
yet any Zoom conversation any recording
where someone typed a password in the
future will be like those Galaxy surveys
where someone will go backwards in time
and and you know Turn Turn up the
information resolution of of that data
yeah I this is pure speculation but I
wonder if I mean imagine anonymized
people in in interviews say 10 years ago
whether they will be able to stay
Anonymous or whether AI will be able to
extract the data about their their face
or their voice that that wasn't wasn't
technically possible when the interview
aired yeah exact exactly there there are
already systems for like dep
pixelating uh you probably do do
something similar for the The Voice
modulation and and then also sort of you
know again going back to like this
ambient information we're always
shedding identifiers in our in the way
we write you know the the kind where we
place a comma uh the kinds of adverbs we
like to use and so forth uh people just
under dramatically underrate you know
how much information we're shedding um
in part because we're blind to it it's
some people who who are taking great
efforts to stay anonymous online people
in in the um cryptography space for
example will will put their writings
through Google translate to French and
then back to English to erase subtle
Clues to to how they to that could
identify them personally why is AI so
much better at tasks like the ones we
just mentioned compared to humans well
it goes back to what we were talking
about with sort of putting information
theoretic bounds on AGI when you
minimize the loss function in a machine
learning model you're you're you're
trying to minimize the cross entropy
loss and cross entropy is how many bits
does it take to distinguish between two
two data streams and if it takes a lot
of bits to distinguish between the two
that means they're relatively
indistinguishable this going again to
the Turing test like if we have have a
Turing test where I can tell right away
that the AI is different from the human
that that suggests a high cross entropy
but if if it take if I to talk to it for
for days and do all kinds of adversarial
questioning I might still be able to in
the end tell the difference between the
two but we've minimized that that cross
entropy loss and so when you have any
arbitrary data distribution that you're
trying to predict whether whether it's
you know trying to predict galaxies and
astronomical data or passwords from
fingerprint data on uh on a on a phone
screen you know all these things embed a
kind of physical memory of the thing in
question and can often be reconstructed
through through this this kind of loss
minimization
where you have a system that ASM
totically extracts the entropy that was
latent in in the data and this can be
done in a way that is often um quite
striking where you know you we can with
stable diffusion make fairly accurate
predictions of what people are imagining
in their
mind using fmri data and fmri data is
like blood flow data in the brain is
very it's a very lossy representation of
what whatever is happening in the brain
but there's still enough latent entropy
in there um that we can kind of reverse
engineer or decompress it into into a
folder picture and this could turn into
to a form of lie detection yeah it I
think it already basically has um if you
have you know fmri
data uh or you know e EGS or other kinds
of like direct brain data is probably
you know it's probably a lot easier but
we already have systems that are are
over 95% accurate uh at detecting
deception from just VIs ual video
recordings we can see how all of this
information that we are continually
shedding gives rise to to the
possibility of of of a leviathan either
of the private or of the government's
kind I wonder what role do do you see
open sourcing AI models playing here
what are the the trade-offs in risks in
in open sourcing AI among the people who
are most bullish to open source there's
often a kind of libertarian ethic underg
guring it right regardless
of whether that's a good idea or not one
of the things I'm trying to communicate
to that to that group is to say that be
careful what you wish for because of
these kind of paradoxical Hoban Dynamics
you know the fact that in America you
never know if someone has a gun or not
you know on the one hand the Second
Amendment enhances her freedom on
another hand you know you don't get the
sort of like everyone's doors unlocked
and people are uh you know like the
police in in in England don't even have
guns like there's a certain Freedom that
that derives from um us not all being
you know heavily
armed um and likewise with with uh open
sourcing powerful AI
capabilities empowers you as an
individual but in general equilibrium
once we all have the capabilities the
world could look much more oppressive
either because we're all spying on each
other all the time and we can all see
through each other's walls or because
there's a backlash and the introduction
of sort of Leviathan type solutions to
restrict our ability to spy on each
other all the time and you know my my
general sense is that we can only delay
we can't really prevent things from
being open source over the long run
because there's a sort of trickle down
of compute requirements but in the
interim you know there are definitely
things that are valuable to open source
you know having 70 billion parameter
language models not not a threat in fact
I think it's probably useful for
alignment research for like that to be
open source but if you are a researcher
and you've developed a emotional
recognition model that can tell if uh
you know with like 90 99% accuracy
whether someone is lying or or or not
lying and whether your girlfriend loves
you or not like these these
things or or or the ability to see
through walls using like I I talk about
uh uh the use of uh Wi-Fi displacement
there people have built pose recognition
models using the displacement of the
electromagnetic frequency of your Wi-Fi
and they can see they can it it's p it's
while penetrating so you can see through
walls like what's the rush to put that
on hugging face um and to like make it
as uh democratized as quickly as
possible I I would say
that if we if we value the adaptation
and mitigation
pathway as as opposed to the Leviathan
pathway then there's a there's a value
in you know Slow Rolling some of these
things how do you think uh government
power will be or relative government
power will be affected by by AI so you
you write somewhere in in this long
series of of blog posts that AI will
cause a net weakening of of governments
relative to to the private sector why is
that yeah specifically Western Liberal
Liberal governments under constitutional
constraints so if you if you imagine
Society being on this kind of knife edge
um I talk about this in the context of
uh Dara mogul's book the Naro Corridor
where he describes liberal democracy as
sort of being in this Corridor between
despotism on the one hand and Anarchy on
the other um and we sort of have to stay
in this saddle path where where society
and the state are are kept in Balance if
you Veer off that path you can on the
one hand you know the state could become
all powerful and that's the sort of
China model more authoritarian digital
surveillance State and indeed you know
China built up their digital
surveillance State and their internet
firewalls and so forth after watching
the Arab Spring and seeing how the
internet was destabilizing to weaker
governments and so I fully expect that
AI will be very empowering and
self-reinforcing of the power of the
Chinese government and indeed their
draft regulations for uh large language
models stipulate that you can't use the
model to undermine National Unity or
challenge the the government and and so
they're baking that in in Liberal
democracies we we think of ourselves as
open
societies and the issue is that we're
only open at The Meta level there's a
public sphere right there's there's
Freedom of Information laws we have we
have we have freedom of speech I don't
have freedom of speech if I walk into a
Walmart wait right the Walmart is
private property in open societies it's
not that we don't have social credit
scores and and and forms of um thicker
forms of social regulation it's just
that we offload those functions onto
private competing private actors whether
it's a
a church that has very strict doctrines
to be me a member or you know other
kinds of of Social Clubs the fact that
you know these days if you want to go to
a comedy club they'll often confiscate
your phone at the door because they
don't want you recording The Comedians
set and putting it online my
anticipation is that because of those
constitutional constraints that that
limit the ability of of liberal
democracies to go the China route right
um because of our civil laws or Bill
bills of Rights and so forth and also
because of lot of procedural constraints
this will naturally shift into the
private sector
and we see that already with the the use
of AI for for monitoring and employment
for for policing speech in ways that uh
would be illegal if done by the state
but are fine if done by by Facebook to
the extent that there's the AI continues
to increase these kind of negative
externalities and there and therefore
puts more value on having a sort of
vertically integrated experience a wall
guard
that can strip out the negative forms of
AI and reinstate a degree of uh Harmony
between
people that uh you know more and more of
our social life will be mediated through
these sort of private organizations
rather than through a a kind of open
public sphere are you're imagining that
uh government services will be gradually
replaced by private services that are
that are better able to respond want
government fight to uphold individual
rights in Walmart or on Facebook you you
are regulated in ways that the
government couldn't regulate you but you
still have the choice to go to uh Target
instead of Walmart or to go to or X
instead of Facebook isn't that the
fundamental thing so the fundamental
thing is the choice between services and
won't governments uphold uh citizens
rights to make those kinds of choices
yeah no I agree and so this this would
be the the defense of the liberal model
is that we allow thicker forms of social
regulation because it's moderated by
choice and competition and the issue
with with you know Chinese Confucian
integralism isn't the uh the fact that
it's uh super uh oppressive it's the
fact that you only have one choice and
you don't have voice or exit so uh yeah
the but it's it's it's obviously a
matter of degree right um when you know
ride hailing first first arose you know
I remember back in 2013 2014 it wasn't
that long ago you know I think Uber was
found it in 20 2009 but it really only
started taking off in the in the early
2010s know people thought it was crazy
to ride a car with a stranger and then
within five years it was the dominant
mode of uh ride haing and in that 5-year
period essentially we saw a kind of
regime change in micro where taxes went
from being something that was regulated
by the state through these uh
commissions that were granted you know
legal monopolies um and used
licensing uh and exams and other sort of
Brute Force ways of insuring quality to
competing private platforms where you
have you know Lyft or Uber to choose
from and they replace the explicit
governance of legal mandates with
compete the competing governance of
reputation mechanisms of uh dispute
resolution systems of uh structured
marketplaces that that that collapse the
the bargaining frictions right you never
have to haggle with an Uber driver you
just sort of get in and that was
obviously a much better way of doing you
know ride haing so even though there was
sort of a violent resistance early on
you know literally like in France they
were throwing rocks off of bridges and
cab drivers in New York were killing
themselves so for the people affected it
was a very dramatic sort of regime
change but for everyone else it was a
positive Improvement and yet it's only
made possible because Uber has a social
credit score if your Uber rating goes
too low you'll get kicked off the
platform um and so we're fine with
social credit scores it's it's when you
only have one and don't have an option
um and it can follow you across all
these different verticals that becomes a
problem do you imagine that because of
of rising danger in the world you talk
about the the externalities from the
widespread uh implementation of of Aon
all all across Society because of those
dangers those externalities you know you
will either use Uber or whatever service
or you're you you kind of can't
participate in in society do do you
imagine increased pressure in that
direction it does seem to be a a longer
term Trend I don't know if AI will you
know accelerate it I I have another
series of essays that I call um
separation
anxiety and it's a reference to the fact
that in in Insurance markets there's
kind of two equilibria there there's the
pooling equilibria where we're pulled
together into one risk pool and there's
the separating equilibria where the the
insurance pool unravels and we break up
into you know the gr power insurance for
like senior citizens who never had a
accident and stuff like that and it
turns out that insurance markets are
competitively unstable that without
government regulation or or social
insurance um that insurance markets will
naturally tend to unravel because of
adverse selection into you know the the
high risk people being in one pool and
the low risk people being in another
Pool and it turns out you can sort of
use that as a mental model to look at
other kinds of uh implicit pooling
equilibria right so in in within company
wage
distributions um often there is you know
20% of the workers who are doing 80% of
the work but they're they're pulled
together under one wage structure and
that was sort of the dominant structure
of of the period of wage compression in
the United States in the 50s and 60s and
once we had better monitoring
Technologies and were able to tell who
who were the 20% that were doing 80% of
the work it suddenly became possible to
to
differentiate pay structure and a lot of
the rise in inequality in United States
is actually uh between firm so what you
know what happens is you know Ezra kle
is like the most productive whiz kid at
the Washington Post and he realizes why
don't I just go start my own website
right and so that that Dynamic sort of
played out across a variety of domains
leads to a world that you know to the
extent that these features are
correlated that does separate right
where you have you know the onear Uber
Riders driving the onestar Uber drivers
the drivers driving the Riders and you
know people who have you know the F star
Uber ratings and the perfect credit
scores self sort into communities with
other people with perfect driving
records and perfect credit scores and
that and you know we see that to an
extent already with the you know
enclaves of You Know Rich Rich zip codes
with private schools and everyone is
sort of self- selected AI could it seems
to me that AI would would exacerbate
that I mean at first blush just because
it going back to the point about signal
extraction it can find all these
different ways you're a high-risk type
and I'm a lowrisk type and so forth that
are probably latent in all kinds of data
um that we don't even need to give
permission to the insurance company
they'll just like the same way that they
use like smoking or going to a gym as a
proxy there's all kinds of proxies they
could use and likewise for employers and
how they pay people Society kind of runs
on us not being entirely open and
entirely honest all the time otherwise
you wouldn't be able to have kind of
smooth social interactions and so on
won't these Norms be inherited by the
way we use AI yeah I think this is a
really big issue um I'm a big fan of
Robin Hansen and uh a lot of his writing
um on social status and signaling is is
sort of a
presenting humans as basically
Hypocrites like we're constantly
deceiving other people um and and and we
often deceive ourselves so it's better
to deceive others as U the uh
evolutionary biologist Robert triers was
pointed out um so you know all the kinds
of
polite uh lies that we tell are I think
critical lubricants to social
interaction and and actually
like it's it's good that there's a gap
between our state and revealed
preference you know I think a world
where we all lived our state preference
could be hellish uh because we don't
actually mean
it um and AI you know has a direct
implication on that because if I can
have a pair of AR glasses on that will
tell me if you're interested if you're
bored if you're if you're on a date and
you know are you really attracted to me
um you know all that sort of polite
veneer that social Veil uh could be
lifted in a way that um we probably want
to coordinate to not do right but again
it's just natur equilibrium where you
know it's in my interest to know whether
you're interested or
bored and so I'll want to have the
glasses on and my ideal world is where
only I have the glasses and you
don't and and the other way that H that
our hypocrisy is being exposed and
challenged is is the need to you know
explicate the utility function that we
want these models to to work under you
know we need to formalize human values
if we want to align these models and so
then we have to be honest and open about
the fact that about the fact that our
state state of preferences probably
aren't are true preferences and that and
that's that's a very challenging thing
because it goes it cuts right to the
nature of of The Human Condition um and
involves topics that are intrinsically
things that we lie our Li to ourselves
about you have what you call a timeline
of a techno futil future which I found
quite interesting yeah it's it's great
writing and it's very detailed we don't
have to go through it all of its detail
but maybe you could you could tell the
story of what happens in what you call
the default scenario this is the
scenario in which Western liberal
democracies are too slow to adapt to Ai
and so we get something like a
replacement of government services with
more private Services what happens in
the techn feudalist future right and and
this sort p piggybacks and everything
you've just been discussing right and
and I don't want techn feudalist to
carry too much of a pejorative um I'm s
of using it
descriptively uh and certainly some
people um would prefer this this uh this
world so the the example of of uber and
lift displacing taxi caps is sort of a
version of this in micro where we go
from this regulated Taxi commission to
competing private platforms that use
various forms of of artificial
intelligence and uh Information
Technology uh to the thing that was
being done by explicit
regulation and as AI progresses um and
both creates a variety of new negative
externalities whether it's like you know
suicide drones or uh or be the ability
to spy on each other um there's going to
be a demand for new forms of security
and Al and also kinds kinds of like
opin uh jurisdictions that like tie our
hands in the same way that we give up
our phone at the before we go going to
the the comedy club and so I think this
leads to a kind of development of
clubs the kind of Club structure uh
maybe at the city level as as the
vertically integrated Walt Garden that
will that will police and and and build
defensive Technologies around the misuse
of AI and at the same time provide a
variety of like new AI native public
goods that are only possible once AI
unlocks them and it's easy to see how
this could very quickly
displace an eat away at at formal
government services both because we saw
it already with with Uber but also um if
you map that that model to other areas
of of regulatory
life you know it doesn't make sense to
have a USDA Farm inspector a human
person has to go to a commercial farm
and uh you know maybe only ghost that
farm once every few years because
there's so many farms and only so many
people and you know does a little
checklist and says oh you're you're not
abusing the animals and like you get all
the process in place and you get the
USDA St of approval um
or does it make more sense to have you
know multimodal cameras on in the uh in
the farm 24/7 that are continuously
generating reports that throw up a red
flag anytime someone sneezes on the
conveyor
belt and to the extent that government
is going to be slow at adopting that
will there be a push for the kind of
uber model of govern governance as a
platform where you have the kind of AI
underwriter the consumer reports that um
sells these firms the camera technology
and the monitoring technology and and
and builds their own set of compliant
standards and then you want to go to
those Farms or or what have you that
have the stamp of approval of that
underwriter because it's much much
higher trust it it's sort of it's sort
of like the end of a symetric
information and you can M map that from
you
know uh food safety to
uh product safety to OSHA and workplace
safety you know there's other parts of
government that maybe just rendered
completely obsolete right like once we
have self-driving cars that are a
thousand Nicks more safe than humans do
we need a national highway traffic
safety
administration uh you know once we have
sensors that are privately owned
everywhere and and can model weather
patterns better than the National
Oceanic Administration do we need a
national weather service or could we
bootstrap that ourselves and then and
then once we have you
know AI accelerated drug Discovery do we
want to rely on the FDA to be a kind of
choke point to do these sort of
frequentist uh clinical trials that um
are inherently slow um and don't capture
the kind of idiosyn syncrasy and and and
um heterogeneity that that could be
unlocked by personalized medicine um or
or do we move to an alternative drug
approval process that is maybe
non-governmental but um much more rapid
and much more personalized that's that's
the overall picture I I'll just uh run
through the timeline here picking up on
some some some of your comments that I
thought were were especially interesting
uh you're right this is this is in in in
20124 to 2027 you write that the
internet will become vulcanized and H
you will have it will become more secure
and more private in a sense why why does
that happen we're already starting to
see this a little bit right um once
people realize that the data that's
being generated on stack Overflow or
Reddit or whatever uh is valuable for
training these models suddenly
everyone's closing their API you know
and and consequently Google searching
Google search and the Google index have
have sort of started to degrade already
so I think that will continue for the
kind of like privatization of of data
reasons then when you also think about
how websites are going to handle sort of
the growth of bots and catfishes and
catfish attacks and and uh cyber attacks
and so forth it makes sense that we're
going to move from a sort of open you
know everything goes kind of Twitter
esque platform to things that are are
much more closed because they require uh
human verification and identity ver
verification to sort of build the trust
that you're talking to other people and
not and not deep fakes and then medium
term again over this sort of 2024 2027
Horizon I you could also start to see
the emergence of uh you know intelligent
malware sort of modern AI native uh
cyber
attacks that uh could be devastating to
Legacy cyber security infrastructure um
in a way that you know I talk about
could hearken back to the the famous
moris worm that uh in the late 80s
basically shut down the early internet
like they literally had to partition the
internet uh and turn it turn it off so
they could R rid the network of the worm
so for all those reasons I think you you
start to see the internet baniz and then
all particularly at the international
level we're we're already starting to
see sort of the um you know
semiconductor supply chain become
critical part of National Security the
growth of you know the Chinese firewall
the European Union is is going to have
to have their own wasi firewall and they
kind of already do with gdpr and the UI
act and so the kind of nationalization
of compute and Telecommunications
infrastructure that will take off once
people understand both the security
risks and the value prop of of owning
the infrastructure for the AI Revolution
yeah in the in 2028 to 2031 you write
about alignment turning out to be easier
than than we thought with the increasing
scale of of the model that that was
somewhat surprising to me why why does
alignment turn out to be easier um and
part of this is is uh you know imagining
a scenario where alignment is easy so we
can talk about
what what happens if alignment is easy
but I think there are reasons to think
that the the classic alignment problem
will be easier than people think I you
know I think that uh some of the early
intuitions about the hardness of the
alignment problem uh were rooted in a
view of you know maybe AI turns out to
be a very simple algorithm rather than
um like a deep neural network that
achieves its generality because of its
depth you know clearly the the kind of
um value I forget what Cas us called it
but the the there's like a a value
alignment problem where how do we teach
the model our values that that part of
the alignment problem seems trivial now
because uh our large language models
aren't like autistic Sant they're
they're actually incredibly uh uh
sensitive to soft human concepts of of
value and and in context we're not going
to have a the paperclip maximizer sort
of monkey paw kind of uh threat models
don't really make sense in that world
but but there's a difference between the
output of the model and the weights or
the the what the model has learned and
so the just because a model can say you
know it can say the right words that we
want it to say but what has it actually
learned we are not entirely sure and so
it has learned to satisfy human values
to some extent but has it learned to has
learned to want to comply with human
value uh out of distribution sort of
yeah in other domains and in a deep
sense I'm not I'm not sure about that no
I agree so so I'm sort of just laying
some of my ground workor for to explain
my priors on this no I agree like you
know reinforcement learning from Human
feedback
is not
alignment in the same way that you know
you could argue that like the
co-evolution of of cats and dogs with
humans led to a kind of reinforcement
learning from Human feedback in in their
in their short run Evolution that you
know made them look appear as if they
you know they experience guilt and shame
and these human emotions when in fact
they're they're just sort of a semil
lacro of those emotions because it means
that we'll um give them a treat but I
I've done plenty of episodes on on
deceptions in in in these models and so
on we we don't have to go through that
uh but I just wanted to point out that
yeah maybe there are some complexities
there so the first my first prior is
that these models aren't autistic Sant
the way they the way they might have
been the second is uh going back to
universality well well it is true that
you there are that you know it's
possible through reinforcement learning
from Human feedback for example that you
you're you're not selecting for honesty
you're selecting for a deep fake of
honesty but in the bigger picture the
intuition that these models are
converging or convergent with uh human
representations should give you some
confidence that they're not going to be
as alien as we as we think they will be
it's also
useful uh input for thinking about
interpretability you know there some
recent work showing that uh discussing
sort of representation interpretability
where where instead of trying to
interpret individual neurons you
interpret sort of collections of neurons
and and U and circuitry and through sort
of human interpretable representations
and one of the one of the lessons of
universality is that like some of these
high level human Concepts like happiness
or uh or anxiety like the these seem
like vague uh psychological
abstractions that there's no way they
can correspond to like the micro
foundations of the way our brain works
but in fact they may actually be very
efficient low dimensional ways of
talking about this what's happening in
our brain and then the third thing is I
think that I I just have seen you know
my sense is that the work on inability
is is actually making some some good
progress you know whether it can scale
is another question but um I think we'll
get there in my timeline I talk about
sort of AGI level models within the you
know human human emulator plus domain I
do later on talk about like super
intelligence emerging maybe in the 2040s
and that's another story right and so I
think some of the stuff maybe goes out
the window if we have you know models
that are bigger than all the brains
combined and have like strong
situational awareness uh but I don't
think that happens uh this decade
certain certainly um certainly not with
the current way we're building these
models the way we're currently building
these models I think it comes much
closer to a simulacro of the human brain
got it in in uh in 2036 to 2039 you talk
about um robotics being solved to the
same extent or maybe even in the same
way as as we are now solving language
that would I found that super
interesting explain to me why why would
robotics suddenly or quite relatively
suddenly become much easier roboticists
have been fighting for decades to get
these these models to to walk
relatively uh unencumbered and it's it's
been an uphill battle yeah why can we
solve robotics in the in the 2030s this
may end up happening sooner than than I
project but
um I mean if you look at llms what one
of the stylized sort of Trends with with
large language models is is that you
know that natural language processing
went from being this you know study of
how to make machines understand language
went from being you know a dozen
different subdisciplines you know you
had people working on ing people working
on syntax people working on semantics
people working on summarization and
classification and these are all
different you know directions research
directions and then Along Comes
Transformer models and you know it just
supplants everything and llms can do it
all and I think robotics is sort of
still in that ancient regime where uh a
lot of you know what Boston Dynamics
doeses is ad hoc control models analy
analytically solvable you know
differential equations different kind
kind of object recognition modules and
and control action loops and so forth
and so it's still in that like early NLP
phase where they have 12 different
subdisciplines and they're sort of
masching them together and of course you
get something that's not very robust I
think we're already starting to see that
paradigm shift to you know end to end
neural network train models like uh you
know Tesla for
instance I think one of the reasons why
Tesla cars um had a sort of uh temporary
decline in performance was because they
were undergoing the transition from
these ad hoc Lane detectors and and stop
sign detectors and stuff like that to a
fully end to end neural network uh
Transformer based model and that tend
turn out to be a much more robust way to
train the model because you you know
stop signs look different in different
countries and like maybe stop sign isn't
the thing you care about really so on
and so forth um and so I think the
Transformer sort of scale deep learning
Revolution is only now coming to
Robotics and people in that field have
are a little bit cynical because they're
used to relatively small RL models
thinking that like the fit with you know
actuators and and some of the hardware
is like a really challenging problem and
also believing that we don't have the
the the data sets for it um but then you
look at you know this recent Robo dog
that you may may have seen on Twitter uh
fully open source robot model
um for a Boston Dynamic style dog it was
trained on h100s you know
10,000 human years of of training and
simulation um and then some fine-tuning
on real world data and they have a very
robust robot control model that you
could plug into all kinds of different
form factors um and have something that
can you know hop gaps and climb stairs
and do all the things that POS Dynamics
robots don't do very well well outside
of their distribution you think we will
have a general purpose algorithm that we
can plug into basically arbitrarily
shaped robots that can then navigate the
navigate our apartments or our
construction sites or maybe our highways
that's that's a that's an interesting
Vision I why why is it that we achieve
this level of generality if you look at
humans you know humans are very good at
U you know if we've suffered an
amputation or you have to go through
physical therapy and it's not easy
necessarily but but humans are able to
adapt to different kinds of uh physical
layouts of our body and I think there
will be a trend
towards uh unified robotic control
models that aren't like super tailored
to you know two legs and two arms and so
on and so forth you know once you've
installed it through a little bit of in
context learning or or fine-tuning or or
reinforcement learning adapt to that
particular form form factor and and this
will parallel the kind of pre-trained
foundation model Paradigm that is
currently taking place in llms where you
have like the the really big foundation
model that can sort of do everything
reasonably well and then you can find
tun it beyond that if we get to the
2040s in in your timeline you talk about
massive amounts of compute being
available you talk about post scarcity
in everything except for land and and
capital and then you also talk about the
development potentially of of super
intelligence at that point what what
happens there who is in control of the
super intelligence if anyone yeah this
is sort of where I start to get a little
bit tongue and Chic but
um you know I I I first of all I talk
about how uh you know I tend to think
that you once we have exoscale Computing
uh you I think doe just built their
first X scale computer maybe it was
Private company but um you know we have
like One X skill computer in the world
by the
2040s they'll be they'll be common place
and if we if we're worried about sort of
you know controlling the supply of gpus
um you know I don't I don't I don't know
I don't know exactly how much compute
will be on our smartphones but it will
definitely be possible to train a you
know gp5 model from your home computer
um and so any kind of uh aicat regime
that we build today that doesn't take
into account that um falling cost of
compute uh will probably break down
um and therefore you know amid this
broader sort of fragmentation of the
machiner of government the state I
expect more and more government
functions to be offloaded into you know
basically private cities uh HOAs gated
communities and likewise with the
internet I expect more and more of our
sort of permissioning regime for new AI
models and deployment to shift to the
infrastructure layer where
uh you know telecommunication providers
will be monitoring Network traffic for
for um unvetted AI models and so forth
and we'll have like Chinese style
firewalls but that are specific to a
particular local area
network and at that point the world
looks the the United States where this
takes place looks more like an
archipelago of micro jurisdictions of um
I tend to think that like a PO post
scarcity political economy is looks
looks a lot like uh the GF States GF
State monarchy right because golf State
monarchies are basically living post
scarcity right they have a spigot of oil
they can turn on um and then they can go
build Mega projects in the desert uh and
they have like infinite labor because
they can just import guest
workers and so you end up with like this
this uh but if if we can't have a golf
State monarchy in the United States
instead we have a bunch of micro
monarchies um dotting the country uh so
I I sort of jokingly say you know um
who's going to stop the free city of
California that's like uh home to all
the trillionaire ml engineers and and
Tech Founders from the decade prior from
um plugging in their their uh Humanity
size supercomputer into a fusion reactor
and turning it on yeah and this is
really your the kind of end point of of
the discussion or your your main point
of of Institutions being eroded and then
afterwards uh being unable to respond uh
to to strong AI yeah and leading up to
this
it sounds like a scary dystopian type of
thing it doesn't have to be right um
Uber is not dystopian arnb is not
dystopian private airports in other
countries are are way better than the
public airports in United States so
privatization and this sort of techn
feudalist Paradigm doesn't have to be
bad but what it what it is is more
adversarial right and you know people
have um sometimes speculated you know
would we have the did the r did the the
crumbling of the Roman Empire ire was
that kind of prerequisite to a
Renaissance right because it allowed for
these principalities to sort of compete
and uh to get the Florentine you know
creativity and so forth um I think you
know the next couple decades could
similarly be a renaissance for Science
and Technology uh and for understanding
the world but but it's partly a
Renaissance because we'll be moving into
a much more competitive adversarial
world where you know these city states
and so forth will be will be hard to
coordinate and and so to the extent that
there are still these like meta risks
where we would value some um large scale
intra and
international coordination like peace
treaties and so forth the the
disintegration of the United States
where this revolution is occurring would
be uh would be bad for that you talk
about or you hint at a an alternative
path what we what we've been talking
about uh your timeline here is the
default path you H to at a a path where
we have something you call constrainted
leviath what is constrainted leviath
it's limited government right so this is
this is um Jen mle's word for it from
the narrow Corridor and if you if you
trace the the rise of sort of
U of what we associate with liberal
democracy it is part of a particular
technological equilibrium in in
particular an equilibrium that that uh
favored centralized governments with
impersonal rule of law and impersonal
Tax Administration and so on and so
forth so we we associate today with
Libertarians with like being
anti-government but the the basic idea
of liberalism is actually associated
with strong government a strong
impersonal government that can impose
the rule of law and so if we want to
maintain that kind of
equilibrium in a world where AI is
diffusing on the society level faster
than it is on the on the on the state
and Elite level then we want to
accelerate the diffusion of AI within
government and there's lot you know
obviously lots of low hanging fruit we
talked about how bureaucracies are
basically flushy apis you know even
today you know I have I have friend a
friend at the uh FTC the Federal Trade
Commission they have like a 30 person
team that that uh is part of the
healthcare Division and they're they're
in charge of you know policing the
entire pharmaceutical industry in the
United States for competition you know
his day job right now looks like
manually reading through 40,000 emails
that they subpoenaed from a
pharmaco right and today you could take
that those emails and put them into you
know CLA 2 or something like it with a
big context window and ask you know five
find me the five most egregious examples
of uh of misconduct um and it would do
that you know it might not be perfect
but it's a hell of a lot more efficient
than reading through the manually and
obviously big law is going to be doing
that and and the pharmac CEO and his his
personal attorneys will be doing that
conversely you know to maintain our
state capacity in the face of of AI is
to you know run in this arms race and um
and you can kind of liken it to uh what
an evolutionary biology they call the
rig Queen Dynamic which comes from Alice
and Wonderland where the rig Queen tells
Alice that sometimes you need to run
just to stay in place and so you know I
think our our government needs to be
adopting this technology as rapidly as
possible so that they can basically
tread water and that means both
diffusing it in existing institutions
but also being open to you know radical
reconfigurations of the machiner
Machinery of government and addressing
some of those firmware level constraints
that we talked about whether it's the
lack of a national identification system
or the outdated outed Information
Technology infrastructure um or the
accumulation of of old procedural kinds
of uh methods of governance a focused
way of doing this is is what you've
you've called for in a political article
which is a a Manhattan Project for AI
safety first question here would it be
better to call it an an Apollo project
as opposed to a a Manhattan Project I
mean the Manhattan Project created some
pretty dangerous weapons whereas the
Apollo project might have been more
benign I mean what what what the Apollo
project and the Manhattan Project have
in common is that they came from an era
of US government where we still built
things where we still had competent
State capacity where we still had you
know a lot of In-House expertise and we
weren't saddled with all these
constraints um so we you know today
couldn't go to the moon in 10 years you
know NASA couldn't you know SpaceX can
and so our modern uh apolla projects are
being done by the private sector through
through competitive contracts and so you
know one of the messages of my piece on
the Manhattan Project is to say the
reason I make this analogy is not just
because AI is a Oppenheimer like
technology but also because responding
to it will require a throwback to that
those kind of institutional forms where
we gave the people at the the top a lot
of discretion and sort of gave them an
outcome um and let them solve for that
outcome without having a bunch of uh
prescriptive rules about how to solve
for that outcome and then and then the
second reason to make the analogy is you
know open Ai and
anthropic uh they both have you know
contingency
plans for developing Ai and having like
a you know runaway Market power right um
you know in the case of open AI it's
their their nonprofit structure in the
case of anthropic it's their public
benefit trust where they both are
envisioning a world where they could
potentially be the first to build AGI
and become basically trillionaires and
so at that point they need to become
basically uh you know governed by a
nonprofit board you know at that at that
point that's not where progress ends
obviously like there's going to be
continued research it would make sense
for the US government to step in and say
let's do this as a joint venture we're
not we're no longer competing in fact
the basic structures of capitalism and
Market competition are starting to break
down let's just pull this together into
a joint venture study the things that
require you know huge amounts of capital
that the private sector doesn't have but
the government can you know the
government the government US government
spent $26 billion doar on the Manhattan
Project and today's dollars when you
think about the financial resources of
of nation state actors to put behind
scaling you know it's nothing like what
Microsoft or Goog Google have you know
what what when's our first uh $200
billion training run right what kind of
things what kind of things can come out
of that I think that's something that
you want to do with the defense
Department's involvement and working
with these companies in a joint way
through you know secur data centers um
and doing kind of like gain of function
style research that really is dangerous
um and and more like you know more
Manhattan Project than than Apollo
project what would be the advantages
here we would be able to spend more to
slow down uh capabilities research and
spend more of our of the res resources
on say mechanistic interoperability or
evaluations or alignment in in general
um because now the the top AI
corporations have kind of combined their
efforts under one government roof yeah
yeah and and and and my in my vision
they're still allowed to pursue their
commercial verticals and I have an
extended version of The Proposal where I
talk about you know needing sort of BIOS
safety Style categories for high- risk
medium risk and lowrisk styles of AI
that very that closely parallels what
anthropic recently put out with their
recommendations for sort of a BSL
categorization of AI research um so I'm
I'm really talking about that like bsl4
lab and Beyond style stuff and some of
that stuff you know some of it will be
to
accelerate alignment and
interpretability research to sort of do
versions of like the open AI super
alignment project where they're
dedicating 20% of their compute to study
alignment
another part of it will be to Forstall
competitive race to the bottom Dynamics
so so that they can coordinate and not
you know violate antitrust laws and then
the the third thing is sort of the the
gain of function stuff that we really
only want to be doing with like very
very strict oversight
compartmentalization kind of pooling of
talent and and uh resources so we can
you know share knowledge on alignment
and safety um but then also because
government has this huge spending power
relative to the private sector you know
anytime you build a supercomputer you're
basically borrowing from the future
you're trying to see what like the
smartphones 20 years from now are will
be capable capable of and so if we want
to sort of get ahead of the curve and
see where scaling is leading then I
think governments uh are really the only
actor that can waste a bunch of money
basically scaling up a system and seeing
seeing what comes out of it yeah when we
talk about about gain of function
research in in AI it's it's an analogy
to to the gain of function research
that's done on viruses in in biolabs but
done for AI models and this could this
could be experimenting with creating
more agent like models
or inducing deception in a model and
planting it in a simulated environment
see what seeing what it does or you know
enticing it to acquire more resources
but again perhaps in a in a safely uh if
if this is even possible in a in a
safely constrained simulated environment
and and this is the type of research
that we could do in in this Manhattan
Project this this government lab because
we would have excellent cyber security
and secure data centers and the combined
efforts of of the most capable people in
in AI research if you've watched
Oppenheimer the movie you know a lot of
that revolved around suspicions of
coming to spies and so on and uh you
know we really don't have great insight
into the operational security of of the
major AGI Labs um and that's something
that you know bringing an inhouse of the
of the defense department would would
they would necessarily have to you know
disclose everything they're doing but
also hopefully beef up their operational
security yeah they're kind of stuck with
a startup mindset but they're they're
not developing a a startup product
they're developing something that uh in
my opinion it could be more dangerous
than than the average startup yeah and
dar dar amade has said as much that we
should just assume that there are
Chinese spies at uh all the major AI
companies and Microsoft and Google when
we think about uh gain of function
research in AI how do you think about uh
the value of of gaining information
about what the models can do and what
the models can't do uh versus the the
risk we're running um it would be a
tragic and ironic death for Humanity if
we experiment Ed with dangerous AI
models to see whether they would destroy
us and then we hadn't constrained them
properly and they they actually
destroyed us so how do you how do you
think of that trade-off between gaining
information and avoiding lab
leaks hopefully lab leaks are less
likely than in the biology context where
um you know getting a little bit of uh
blood or urine on your on your shoes as
you walk at the door you know it's it's
a difficult thing to to talk about in
part because we just went through a
pandemic that very probably was caused
by bsl4 lab leak and so you know one
Saving Grace is that AI models don't get
caught in your respiratory
system um uh and so hopefully there's
forms of compartmentalization that are
much much more robust than in the
biology context and to the extent that
this research is going to be done anyway
you know it' be much better to move it
offsite and hopefully in a way you know
facilities are air gapped and so forth
rather than you know what you know
Microsoft is doing right now they
Microsoft just recently announced their
autogen AI which are sort of agent-based
models um very similar to like autog GPT
but like that
work and they're doing this through a
Creative Commons totally open source uh
framework all this all this capabilities
work is gain a function research where
we draw the line between doing things
that are intentionally dangerous or
doing things that are dangerous but we
we're kind of pretending that they're
not um is is hard I I do think there's
and Paul Cristiano's also agreed with
this sort of threat models that we would
be valuable to be running in Virtual
machines and to see you know if the AI
comes develops awareness situational
awareness and tries to escape but
escapes into a simulated world that we
buildt for it okay let's end by talking
about a recent critique of expecting a
AI um to to arrive pretty uh in in a
short time this revolves around interest
rates and um I guess the basic argument
is or the basic question is if AGI is
imminent uh why are real interest rates
low I can explain it but you're the
economist so maybe you can explain the
reasoning here so it's it's really a
question of how efficient are markets
and and how much foresight do markets
have you know we're coming out of a
world of very low interest rates of
ultra low interest rates near zero
interest rates and one way one way to
think about that is there's a surplus of
savings relative to investment and so
one of the reasons interest rates have
been in secular decline is because
populations are aging and so old people
have a huge amount of savings built up
um and Meanwhile we're going through the
S technological stagnation so the amount
of savings relative to the amount of
profitable Investments uh was out of
whack and so that pushes interest rates
down in a world where AI takes off it's
a world where we have enormous
investment opportunities where we'll be
building data centers left and right and
not we can't do it fast enough where
there's new products new new commercial
opportunities left and right um and so
you would expect uh in that world where
the singularity is near so to speak uh
to be one where the markets begin
forecasting rapidly Rising interest
rates because the savings to investment
balance is starting to shift and in
addition there's a long run stylized
fact that that interest rates real
interest rates track growth rates
um and so if GDP growth GDP growth takes
off you'd also expect at least nominal
rates to to also take off um and so some
have argued that looking at current
interest rate data like the you know the
5ye 10 year 30-year treasury bonds that
the markets are not predicting AGI you
know the two responses to that are one
first of all interest rates are up quite
a
bit nothing's monocausal there's lots of
confounding factors um is this to some
extent the Market's
anticipating a an investment boom you
know maybe not they're not anticipating
full AGI but they're they're seeing the
way llms are going to impact you know
Enterprise and and sort of piing some of
that in and then the second piece would
be okay to the extent that they're not
pricing in AGI how much foresight 2
markets have anyway before we discuss uh
market efficiency I just want to just
give a couple of of intuitions here uh
if AGI was imminent and uh it would it
it was on Alliance say and it would
destroy the world in five years well
then it doesn't make a lot of sense to
save money similarly if if AGI is about
to to explode growth rates well then a
lot of money will be available in the
future you're about to become very rich
so it doesn't make sense to to to save a
lot now and the the pool of available
savings determine what's available for
Lending which determines uh interest
rates but uh let's let's discuss yeah
whether markets then are efficient on
this issue or to what extent they're
efficient right so this is the efficient
market hypothesis which which um comes
in strong and weak forms so the strong
form of the efficient market hypothesis
would say that markets aggregate all the
available information and our best sort
of Point estimate of anything we we care
about the weaker form uh which I think
is uh more defensible is that markets
can be wrong but you but they can be
wrong longer than you can be solvent
right and so you can you can try to
short a company that like Herbal Life
you know famously there was a big short
position on that and because Herbal Life
sort of looks like it's a multi-level
marketing Ponzi scheme but yet the the
the hedge fund that did that lost you
know several billions of dollars before
they ended their position because the
markets were stayed irrational longer
than they could stay solvent the second
factor is the weak the weaker versions
of the efficient market hypothesis are
sort of based on a no Arbitrage
condition
right they say markets are efficient
only in so far as you can
Arbitrage an inefficiency right and so
you know you look at some prediction
markets for example um they predict it
they'll they'll often have very clear um
inconsistencies across markets that look
like they're irrational but then you
realize oh I can only make like $7,000
total in the on the website and there
are transaction fees and I have to you
know there's work involved and so if the
market isn't very deep or liquid there
may be inefficiencies that exist not
because the Market's inefficient but
it's as efficient as it can be under the
circumstances and when it comes to AI
you
know how do you Arbitrage uh you know
I've been thinking for a while now that
shutter
stock their their their market cap
should be collapsing right because you
know we have image generation uh that is
proliferating and yes people will make
the argument though shutter stock has
all this uh all this image data they
could build a better image model you
know maybe it seems like it's
cannibalizing their business it's sort
of turning a mo into a commodity and yet
shutter stocks uh market cap has
basically held constant throughout this
uh recent Rebirth of image birth of
image image generation models what if
you borrow a lot of money uh cheaply and
then put it into an index of of
semiconductor stocks or or just it
companies in general or even just the
general S&P 500 today would that be a
way of arbitraging uh this AI forecast
yeah I would say if you have short
timelines you should be putting a lot of
money into equities this is not
Financial advice would you say right and
that's I mentioned earli earlier that
you know Paul Cristiano has said in
interviews that he's twice levered into
the stock market he basically owns a
bunch of AI exposed companies and he's
he's borrowed you know his enough money
to double his Investments uh so that's
you know putting your money where you're
is when you look at Market Behavior over
the long stretch of time you know
markets didn't anticipate the internet
very well um you know there was a a
short run bubble um that led to a boom
and bust of of Doom stocks but in terms
of the real economy the internet just
kept chugging along it kept being built
out and eventually the eventually a lot
of those Investments ended up paying off
even if you you know rode through the
bubble you know markets are made up of
people some of the biggest Capital
holders in the markets are institutional
investors Pension funds uh life
insurance companies um governments you
know like the uh sa Saudi Arabia or the
Norwegian pension fund and often these
are you know making safe bets you know
that they're not taking very het orox
views on on on markets um and so as a
result markets can be a little bit
autoaggressive they're a little bit
biased to the Past you know past
prologue and and prone to kind of M
multiple equilibria where there's two
prices that shutter stock can be shutter
stock could be a $50 stock or it could
be a z stock and at some point the
market will update and we will undergo
through like the great repricing and all
these asset prices will flip in
relatively short order the efficient
market hypothesis has to be false or
else we wouldn't have Silicon Valley
right we wouldn't have Founders that
that we wouldn't have Elon Musk right so
I would just say the markets are wrong
and partly they're wrong because to be
right would require having a bunch of
relatively uh bespoke and kind of
esoteric priors about the direction of
the technology that are only now just
sort of percolating into the mainstream
yeah and that the big kind of capital
allocators can't really respond to
because they're risk ofers exactly um no
that doesn't mean like Renaissance
Technologies won't respond to it but
they're not going to move the market
Samuel thanks for this conversation and
I've I've learned a lot thank you